references and everyone's here for their
financial telecommunication company so I
was us openly full access to education
countries where it's an easy I believe
this is a very difficult question to
answer because there's not a thing of
felicity the obvious things just is
building schools and making some paper
online education of those five so maybe
three because family together what I
believe it's much more confident and
informational shouldn't come the time
that they are not needed to work in the
fields so I will see some measurements
of raising overall is the standard of
living in individuals and make sure that
we can feel the language english ave
hammond because it's cool i also some
examples in Africa where we've been
helping to from the time of the model so
that the gloves envy care of children
and tell them if executed